do authorities believe that they have
much to work with here well Tricia's you
know the executioner there did have a
mask on trying to hide his identity in
that video but he and his accomplices
I'm told did leave some clues behind
that's according to current and former
intelligence officials who have looked
at this video a former French hostage
says he may even recognize the masked
man is that a British jihadist who he
referred to as John now the hunt is on
for jailer John
I spoke with Patrick sue fan he's a
former CIA case officer now at the
soupçon group to get an idea of what
investigators are looking at first
Patrick Skinner tells me technicians
going to scrub the video for any
metadata left behind they're looking
specifically for a timestamp location of
the computer used to upload this video
they'll also want to know who downloaded
it right away that could provide some
clues next they're going to focus on the
video production itself and Skinner
tells me that the panorama style
shooting in broad daylight very bold and
unusual it tells him that they weren't
worried about being spotted from the air
they weren't worried about drones like
they should have been Skinner says that
and the desolate desert backgrounds
suggest to him that it was shot in Syria
away from the Iraqi border if they can
get more on the time and location of
Foley's murder then Trish they can go
back and look for communication traffic
around that time that could be a
critical component in this manhunt maybe
the best clue of all the voice on the
video itself this is James Wright Foley
an American citizen country now the
British voice but the slight accent
already suggests to linguist he's from
the southeast of London most likely from
South East of England most likely from
London Skinner says that audio is gonna
be mashing his audio and terror
databases but Trish the curveball here a
UK intelligence official tells us it's
possible the voice and the man in the
video not the same person yeah that
absolutely makes sense I just have a
question I mean it's it's interesting to
hear all this information and to know
what kind of clues they'll be looking at
but at the same time do authorities run
the risk that these terrorists are going
to be able to effectively get away
because there's so much information out
there how do you balance this well
there's a lot of information Trish but
again they're clues within this video
and that is important this was bold the
way they did it but they did leave some
telltale marks that they have to work
with and one of them is even the the
executioner's physical appearance itself
his face is covered he's wearing all
black but there are things that they can
determine from the images themselves
there's no chance for a retinal match
I'm told but the eyes alone can lead to
facial recognition for example that's
according to a michigan state biometrics
expert Anil Jane says 70% of the of the
face is the eye area that could be all
they need potentially to try and
identify him he also appears in the
video to be left-handed that's another
clue for investigators Trisha bottom
line this is going to be very difficult
but it will be possible